far from the battlefields of ukraine
peaceful kaliningrad could emerge as a
new focal point in the war the region
has changed hands over the centuries
most recently after the second world war
when the soviet union annexed it from
germany about half the size of vancouver
island kaliningrad is a russian exclave
on the baltic sea sandwiched between eu
members poland and lithuania it relies
on russian goods sent by rail through
belarus and lithuania since new eu
sanctions came into effect last friday
its governor says 50 percent of imports
are being blocked including coal and
construction materials
russia's security council secretary
visited on tuesday saying the
consequences will have a serious
negative impact on lithuania and its
people what exactly that means for the
nato member is as yet unclear
lithuania's prime minister says the
situation is the result of an eu
sanction and not a lithuanian blockade
the eu's ambassador to moscow was
summoned to the russian foreign ministry
on tuesday i appealed to the russian
side
to remain cool-headed
not to escalate
but de-escalation isn't a term vladimir
putin is using
the russian president told military
graduates that russia's newest
intercontinental nuclear missile will be
in operation by the end of the year as
he outlined plans to modernize the
country's armed forces
meanwhile the german and british
governments repeated their pledges to
further arm ukraine too we're determined
to provide more weapons impose more
sanctions and back ukraine in pushing
russia out of their territory the slow
and bloody fight for that territory
continues from both sides in the donbass
ukraine says russia has captured some
territory there in recent days but a
former senior u.s commander says the
arrival of more western weapons could
soon turn the tide in favor of ukraine
redmond shannon global news london